the townsfolks scream and run in Terror
their flaming torches and pitchforks
falling from their trembling hands
behind them scp-096 Wars in monstrous
rage it will kill every single one of
them and to think this had been the
happiest few weeks of its life not long
before
scp-096 is one of the most fearsome
anomalies ever contained by the SCP
Foundation responsible for nearly as
many containment breaches and personal
casualties as scp-682 the shy guy is
known for only a few things its long
pale limbs its tendency to huddle in the
corner of its cell weeping and the fact
that anyone who sees its face is doomed
to meet a horrible violent fate most of
the researchers and civilians alike who
have crossed scp-096 is passed would
have no trouble describing it as a
monster and some might even use stronger
language than that but though SC p096 is
certainly frightening to behold and
often deadly to those who behold all of
it the shy guy is not a monster not to
everyone once upon a time it even had a
friend many many years ago before the
SCP Foundation First contained scp-096
it was just a pale figure that hid from
sight in the dense snowy Forest on a
remote Mountainside there its long lanky
body and unnaturally pale complexion
allowed the creature to blend in with
the landscape skin like snow and arms
and legs like branches and slender tree
trunks no one ever came into its domain
saved for the occasional lost hiker and
it was easy enough for the shy guy to
duck out of sight when they did come in
the warmer months Crews of lumberjacks
would come through and the shy guy would
have to be more careful with its hiding
moving quickly to keep its face obscured
from The Strangers none of them ever saw
its face though they could feel its
presence it would whisper amongst
themselves about the feeling of being
watched recalling old Lumberjack Legends
of the hide behind a creature that
stalked through forests and hid itself
behind the trees whenever its prey
turned to look the shy guy was not
trying to hunt them it only wanted to be
left alone but the Lumberjack still
glanced over their shoulders nervously
as they went about their work swapping
scary stories around the campfire at
night when the work was done but other
than a rustling Branch a flash flight
darting between the trees or the
occasional set of unnaturally large
footprints in the snow they never saw
the creature they could sense sharing
the woods with them it was for the best
that they didn't they wouldn't have
survived if they had managed to catch a
glimpse of its face the shy guy was
happy with its home or at least as happy
as it could be about anything in its
life it was a lonely existence never
letting anyone truly see it the
creature's life was ruled by fear and
isolation the terror that one day its
face would be spotted and it would be
unable to control what it did next late
at night when the world was asleep save
for a few owls nestled in the branches
up above and scanning the ground for
mice to eat the shy guy would let itself
truly feel the weight of its suffering
crying so hard it sobs shook the tree
line but other times when the land was
still and quiet when a fresh snowfall
blanketed the Earth and soft white
powder and all living things were hiding
in a warm place until Springtime came
scp-096 felt something like peace the
dead of winter was its safest time a
time where it wouldn't need to listen
for every sound and await potential
Intruders but of course winter never
lasted eventually spring would always
come the first blade green grass would
poke up through the melting snow and
life would return to the Shy Guy's
Forest one day the Shy Guy's guard
dropped and it made a grave mistake it
allowed someone to get too close before
looking for a hiding spot a man from one
of the lumber camps setting up nearby
saw the creature's face the man screamed
in shock and Terror but his screams were
soon drowned out by the raw animalistic
Bellow of the shy guy as it flew into an
uncontrollable frenzy of rage and
despair chasing the man through the
forest at Breakneck speed it was far
faster than the man running on longer
stronger legs than any human could have
when he caught up to the man in a
foreign part of the forest that the
creature had not seen before it silenced
his screams for good all at once the
creature was alone once more then came
the remorse the inevitable feeling of
deep devastating loss that came over it
every time it destroyed a person who had
seen its face the same cycle over and
over again Relentless and unceasing
though it should have gotten used to the
whole thing by now it broke for the poor
creature's heart succumbing to sadness
scp-096 lumped to the ground cradling
its head and its massive hands and began
to cry are you all right there are you
hurt a voice suddenly interrupted the
creature's private lament it froze at
the sound before lifting its head to
seek out the source of the interruption
who was that where were they did it have
time to hide before they could see its
face the shy guy opened its eyes to see
an old man standing only a few feet away
from it holding a cane the man was
facing it his eyes aimed towards the shy
guy's face but they were unfocused they
could not see the shy guy didn't
entirely understand how but I knew that
the man was unable to see its face for
the first time in a very long time it
felt relief wash over it
stop crying can you speak the man walked
closer to the creature concerned
furrowing in his brow here take my hand
and come inside where it's warm I'll get
you a blanket and something to eat the
old man held out his hand expectantly
and slowly hesitantly
scp-096 placed its hand in his my you're
a big fellow if you can stand come with
me I will get you all sorted out unsure
but too surprised to do anything else
the shy guy silently followed the old
blind man into a nearby cabin inside it
was indeed warm the small yet Pleasant
space lit by a crackling fire in the
Hearth it was the nicest place as cp096
had ever been cozy and dry no snow or
mud to be found every surface was smooth
or soft made for living comfortably the
old man led the creature to a little
dining table and pulled out a chair her
inviting it to sit down he prattled on
about how nice it was to have some
company for once even if his new
companion was unable to speak he had
plenty to say and was happy to fill the
silence enough for the both of them he
turned on a radio and it came to life
with the sound of music and crackling
static then he busied himself at the
wood fire stove where a pot of soup was
simmering he poured two bowls of soup
one for him and one for the Shy Guy and
placed them both on the table
scp-096 wasn't sure of what to make of
the cabin the soup or the spoon that the
old man handed it to go with the meal
after a moment of watching the old man
eat however he began to understand that
it was food it disregarded the spoon in
favor of picking up the bull and
drinking straight from it the broth meat
and vegetables warmed the Creature From
the Inside Out in a way it had never
felt before and for once the shy guy
made a sound other than a scream
the old man laughed delightedly and
agreed that the soup was indeed very
good the two ate the rest of their meal
and the old man placed a heavy blanket
on the couch for the creature inviting
it to stay for the night in fact it
could stay as long as it wanted Mikey
had said the old man could really use
the company as well as an extra pair of
hands to help out around the house this
could he said be an arrangement that
benefited them both with that the old
man went to bed leaving the shy guy
alone for the night they considered
leaving while the man slept slinking
back off into the forest and
disappearing but as it pulled the
blanket over its body it felt a sense of
warmth and comfort enveloping it this
was a safe place one where no one would
catch it unaware and look at its face
maybe it could stay at least for a
little while before long the Shy Guy's
eyes closed and it drifted off to sleep
the Shy Guy and the old man quickly fell
into a routine from there the old man
taught the creature how to tidy up
around the cabin how to chop wood and
use it to keep the stove and fireplace
lint he showed it how to open cans of
beans and retrieve meat from the cabin
Smokehouse so they could fix their meals
and introduce the creature to all of his
favorite stations on the radio all the
while the old man talked telling the
creature stories of his life his time in
the Army how he met his wife how it felt
to lose her how difficult it was to
raise his children alone and how
rewarding it was to see them go off and
start families of their own during one
of these stories the old man remarked
that his family would be coming out to
visit soon and bring him some supplies
to help him through the rest of the
winter before the warm weather returned
the shy guy should have understood what
that meant should have planned to leave
before the Man's family arrived but it
was so overwhelmed by the joys of its
new life that it didn't even consider
the possibility in this moment it seemed
that things would always be perfect one
morning the shy guy awoke to the sound
of a knock at the door it jolted awake
at the sound gasping with fear the Old
Man rushed into the room grinning
excitedly he told the shy guy not to be
afraid that it was only his son coming
to visit but scp-096 panicked it had to
cover its face now as the old man opened
the door to welcome his son inside the
shy guy quickly buried his face in his
hands shielding it from the young man's
eyes though the young man did not Doom
himself by seeing the creature's face he
couldn't help but cry out in shock at
the sight of his father's house guest he
tried to explain to his father that this
was not an ordinary man in need of
shelter but rather some sort of terrible
monster he described the shy guy to his
father its lack of clothing its
emaciated form and impossible height but
the old man would not listen to a word
he shoot his son out of the cabin
insisting that if he was going to be
rude to his guest and he could go ahead
and see himself out he told his son that
the shy guy no matter how strange it
might look had been a great help and
comfort to him and he would not tolerate
a rude word against his new friend he
slammed the door shut then apologized to
scp-096 for his son's Behavior meanwhile
his son was distraught his poor father
living alone with a monster he could not
sit idly by while this continued he
rushed into town and told everyone all
about what he had seen local Lumberjacks
spoke up with their own stories telling
him about the legends of the hide behind
and The Lumberjack who had gone out on a
job in those woods and never returned
home this creature living with the old
man had to be the same monster the
townspeople decided that enough was
enough and they were going to take back
the forest and handle this monster
problem once and for all they grabbed
whichever weapons they could find from
hunting rifles and kitchen knives to
pitchforks and torches all the while
they worked themselves up into a frenzy
of fear and anger before long the once
peaceful people of the Town had formed
into an angry mob with the old man's son
at the helm killed the monster they
cheered as they stormed into the forest
and towards the old man's cabin the old
man opened his door expecting to find
his son standing there again and was
greeted instead by everyone from his
town armed to the teeth and ready for a
fight they demanded to see the monster
that he was keeping inside when he
refused A group of men grabbed him by
the arms dragging him out of the cabin
as he protested they insisted that they
were doing this for his own good to
protect him from the Hideous Beast he
had unknowingly welcomed into his own
home he struggled to break free but he
was not as strong as he had been in his
Youth and he was outnumbered
scp-096 watched as its friend was pulled
from the cabin and taken outside and it
was unable to stop itself from
intervening it ran out of the front door
where the angry mob was waiting neither
scp-096 nor the mob were prepared for
what happened next when the dozens of
people standing there with their
pitchforks and torches all found their
eyes locked directly onto
scp-096's face the creature had been
upset before but now it was positively
Furious its mouth stretched into a
shriek that echoed off the Mountainside
as it began to rip through the crowd
like tissue paper massive arms swinging
and knocking over people left and right
until no one was left standing some of
the townspeople tried to fight back to
prod at the creature with their
Pitchfork or swipe at it with the Flames
of their torches but the attacks didn't
even slow the shy guy down bullets fired
from the feet of hunting rifles
ricocheted off the creature's skin not
leaving so much as a dent as it tore
through the crowd by the time it was
through there was no one left except for
the old man and his son the old man
called out to the creature asking what
had happened asking if it was all right
but as always the creature could not
answer and even if it could it wouldn't
have said a word at that moment its
focus was elsewhere its eyes trained on
the old man's son the only person who
had seen its face and was still alive
the young man ran off into the forest as
fast as he could tripping over his own
feet as The Terror made him too clumsy
to see straight the attempt to escape
was in vain and the shy guy took no time
at all to catch up with him he grabbed
the young man in its hands lifted him
into the air as he squirmed and fought
to break free then it unhinged its jaw
and swallowed him whole when the shy guy
quieted all of its prey disposed of it
heard the voice of the old man in the
distance calling out for his friend he
knew then that I could never go back to
the only person who had ever shown it
kindness it would not be safe for either
of them instead it would return to the
deep deep forest to the life of solitude
but it would never forget that time in
the cabin or the only man who ever made
scp-096 feel as if it wasn't a monster
at all now go check out scp-096 versus
siren head and scp-096's sad end for
more